you made dumb and Dumberer and we're
taking a left turn here but did you know
that that movie would be as big as it
became and as iconic as it became did
you know what you were making at the
time I was making a comedy with Jim
Carrey that's what I knew mm-hmm and
comedic genius he we knew
fourteen-year-old boys would love it but
I wasn't prepared for the guys in there
you know 70s with the tuxedo and the
martini and the portfolio coming up and
going you know Dumb and Dumber might be
the best movie I know
[Laughter]
[Applause]
the great that was weird you know that
was for the memory yeah that was a that
was a great old-fashioned yeah you know
no idea
Joe had no idea that you were coming out
I thought for sure they'd tell them no
but that's great that they didn't and
you know because I wanted to come out
here and say it in front of the world
you're in town and you don't call me and
I thought about it I thought about
better angels you guys can't go out
together you can't go to a restaurant
together because people are gonna think
we're ripping do over go anywhere
together get a good table yeah sure for
sure we went yeah you know and I love
you know I've been watching all the
press and stuff I got to tell you this
this loony tower thing sounds funny ya
know I love being around and though
especially you know I've been watching
your press and you know I watch
everything he does he's incredible the
most versatile actor working today
unbelievable all the things he does and
and I especially enjoy watching you do
interviews because I know you love them
especially the parts were you where you
talk about how working with me changed
the course of your life
[Applause]
it did it did it did there was an
adjustment yes yeah it did what I mean
shooting Dumb and Dumber with Jim was I
mean you grab on to the tornado that is
Jim Carrey and you hang on and it was
such a joy it was such a joy as a blast
even the second one okay wasn't as
well-received around the colostomy bag
keep it up here in a cowboy how did you
know you would have that chemistry whose
idea was it because you two under you
see it right here right now
instantaneously you just connect on the
molecular level it's like that when I
saw him there was a tingling in my groin
that's the sign that's when I know I'm
with the right person it's a growing
thing that's right you see you see you
know there have been comedians that had
come in and there were other big stars
that had come in comedians always trying
to score yeah but Jim wanted an actor
and and smartly you know I when I got on
you want Jim Carrey to be Jim Carrey you
want that and so did I and so Lloyd
always went through the door first cuz
that's Jim Jim's gonna here we go boom
Lloyd is selfish
whatever but debt debt so Harry put me
on a leash and jerk me and that's what
that's what the relationship yeah it was
as soon as we started reading together
it was a real relationship Dustin
Hoffman called me and he said that is
the most real relationship
buddy relationship I've seen in movies
and decades and I went get out of who's
this and and fortunately he couldn't
grab me because he was on the phone
[Laughter]
I haven't seen you in a while either no
I call a lot you I call you constantly
hold and moved into my neighborhood he's
like three houses a couple of houses
away yeah and and you know came over
once that's not sure I came over a
couple of times okay a couple of times
yeah but I figured we were gonna have a
real buddy thing going on and stuff like
that it was just like then it was just
like every once in awhile I saw a
pompadour go go back and forth over the
top of the fence and you never came I'm
like a shark fin just going back at
church like hung out at your place a
couple galleries very nice it was very
nice beautiful play I'd like to have a
friendship with you I'm a really busy
guy you know on TBS and that's a pretty
high perch
[Music]
I'm going up there right there I'm going
up there this is very nice it's really
nice that you know I guess you found out
we're gonna be doing some stuff later on
we'll be doing some stuff later I'm
gonna shoot something with you yeah I
have a show called kidding on Showtime
and Conan has been nice enough to do a
piece on it and we're all gonna do it
together thank you thank you I'm so glad
I'm so gonna be on it and she's suckin
the focus like all right well knows all
the tricks I'm gonna wrap this thing up
because yeah I mean I get paid the same
either way mr. Jeff Daniels mr. Jim
Carrey thank you so much for being here
[Applause]
you